dustin diamond has died
a rep for the former child star
confirmed to e.t that the saved by the
bell star
died monday morning he was 44.
dustin was diagnosed with carcinoma just
weeks ago and the deadly cancer spread
rapidly through his system
dustin's rep told et the actor did not
suffer
and they're grateful it wasn't painful
mr screech
i need to borrow your brain no way zack
you still haven't returned my tricycle
from kindergarten
dustin was well known for playing
screech on the hit
90s sitcom his performance created one
of the most
memorable tv characters of all time we
each have our little differences
but it would come out being friends in
the end he went on to star in the
spin-off
saved by the bell the new class to speak
with mr belding press two and to talk to
screech
don't press anything cause it's me but
was absent from the recent revival on
peacock
there seemed to be some hope that he
would join the series for season two
is there any chance that we would maybe
see dustin diamond
we definitely hear about screech like
where there's jokes about what he's
doing now and there's
some easter eggs about his life or
whatever if you look closely in the show
i'd love to see screech and i i would be
open to it
if there was another season his co-star
tiffany thiessen posted
this tribute to instagram after news of
dustin's passing broke
quote life is extremely fragile and it's
something we should never take for
granted
godspeed dustin and mark paul gossler
tweeted
deeply saddened to hear of the passing
of dustin diamond
a true comedic genius my sincere
condolences to his family and friends
looking back at our time working
together i will miss those raw brilliant
sparks that only he was able to produce
a pie in your face my comrade e.t will
bring you more as hollywood reacts to
the actor's tragic death